الجنرال كلارك ، هل يمكنك رؤية الأخبار الواردة
من أوكرانيا ، ما الذي تقوله لك عن
فعالية أنظمة باتريوت
مقابل الصواريخ الروسية الفائقة السرعة
لأنني أعني أنه قد تم وصفها
بأنها شبه مستحيلة لاعتراضها
بشكل جيد وهذا ما قاله السيد بوتين ولكن اتضح أنه
أن باتريوت يمكنه اعتراض
صاروخ فرط صوتي بعد أن تم
تصميم باتريوت من خلال اعتراض
الصواريخ الباليستية التي كانت قادمة
ولذا فهم يقومون بتحريكه
أكثر من ثلاثة أو أربعة أضعاف سرعة
الصوت لذا أه يمتلك باتريوت رادارًا
نظام التوجيه والطاقة
في الصاروخ ليكون قادرًا على ضرب
صاروخ فرط صوتي وارد ، هل تعلم أعني
مدى ضخامة روسيا التي تزود هذه
الصواريخ الفائقة الصوت ، أعني أنها تستطيع
الاستمرار في استخدامها في
أجواء الهجوم التي أعتقد
أنها  أه إنها حقًا
مسألة لوجستية لكلا الجانبين ،
السؤال هو كم عدد صواريخ باتريوت التي
يمكن لأوكرانيا أن تطلقها ، وعندما أنظر
إليها ، فإن أندرسون هو نوع من
الحسابات الاستراتيجية من قبل الروس لمحاولة
استنفاد الأوكرانيين صواريخ مسببة للتهيج
قبل ذلك الوقت  تشن أوكرانيا
هجومها الرئيسي حتى تتمكن روسيا من
نشر طائرات ITS التكتيكية في
دور جو-أرض ضد
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني الذي نبيعه ، رأينا
مؤسس مجموعة Wagner ادعى أن
مقاتلًا أمريكيًا قُتل في
باك moot.  لقد ارتكبت روسيا
خطأً في تركيز الكثير من قواتها
على وضع باخ ، لا أعني فقط
مجموعة فاجنر ولكن أيضًا الجيش الروسي الرئيسي أيضًا
يبدو لي بالتأكيد أنه خطأ
قد لا نعرف أبدًا لماذا فعلوا ذلك ولكن
يبدو أنه كذلك  أصبح
هدفًا رمزيًا ، ومن الواضح أن القيادة العليا الروسية
قد أخبرت جنرالاتها اتخاذ
خطوة باك لا تهتم بما تكلفته ، فقط
احصل عليه ، لذا فقد ألقوا
عددًا لا يحصى من الاعتداءات هناك واختاروا
الكثير من الخسائر والآن هم
عرضة للتطويق الفعلي
من قبل الأوكرانيين وهذه ستكون
هزيمة رمزية كبيرة لروسيا ، فقد
تفتح الطريق أمام
هجوم مفاجئ يمر مباشرة من خلال
باك مووت من قبل الأوكرانيين في
قلب المواقف الروسية ما رأيك في
سيأمل الدفاع الأوكراني في تحقيق هدف
مثالي ، حيث سيواجه الأوكرانيون
هجومًا في الجنوب باتجاه شبه
جزيرة القرم ،
لكن علينا أن نكون مستعدين
لنفاجأ بوجود أكثر من
محور هجوم واحد
في الشمال.  واحد في الشرق
باتجاه مزاج باخ أو دونيتسك ثم واحد
في الجنوب ربما يكون استطلاعًا لميليتا أو
ربما سيذهبون عبر Nipper uh
بالقرب من كيرسون ، ونحن لا نعرف حقًا
ومن المحتمل أن يكون لديهم
خيارات متعددة في هذا  لذا من
المحتمل أن يكون الهجوم المضاد على أندرسون قيد التنفيذ في
الوقت الحالي ، فنحن لا نراه ونقوم
بالاستطلاع والقوة لمهاجمة
العمود الفقري اللوجستي للروس الذين يحاولون أن
يكونوا قادرين على منع إعادة انتشار
الروس  القوات من خلال الضربات الانتقائية ،
نشهد فقط بداية
ذلك مع صواريخ Storm Shadow التي
قدمتها المملكة المتحدة ، لذا يبدو لي
أنها المرحلة الافتتاحية لأربعة أشهر من
الهجوم المضاد